alors que le gouvernement commence
doucement à préparer le terrain pour le
déconfinement et à mettre en place
toutes les mesures barrières pour éviter
que le virus puisse continuer sa
transmission voilà qu'un contrôle
sanitaire qui vient d'avoir lieu
inquiète au plus haut point c'est le
laboratoire de la régie municipale eau
de paris qui est à l'origine de ces
relevés hier dimanche lors d'un contrôle
de la qualité des eaux de la capitale
les agents de la sécurité sanitaire
aurait retrouvé d'infimes traces du coc
vie de 19 dans l'autre parient en effet
sur quatre des 27 points de contrôles
habituels les traces ont été détectées
poussant la mairie de paris à stopper
temporairement son écoulement pour faire
des études plus poussées
d'après les autorités c'est dans le
réseau non potable que ces traces ont
été détectées une eau provenant de la
scène et du canal de l'ourcq qui est
utilisée pour arroser les jardins ou
encore procéder au nettoyage des rues
pour l'adjointe à la mairie de paris en
charge de la santé anne souyris cela ne
représente aucun risque de consommer de
l'eau du robinet qui provient quant à
elle des réservoirs d'eau potable de la
ville pourtant cette information a de
quoi inquiéter et même à la mairie de
paris qui pourrait prendre la décision
de nettoyer désormais les rues de la
capitale avec de l'eau potable pour
éviter tout risque d'infecter les
trottoirs alors des traces de
coronavirus retrouver dans l'autre paris
êtes vous inquiet alors la mairie paris
a tout de suite voulu rassurer en
affirmant que les quantités du virus
était un film et qu'ils avaient
directement stopper l'utilisation de
cette au regard des hri privé de son
réseau d'eau non potable des traces de
kovy 19 filles ont été détectés les
quantités sont infimes indique la mairie
et concernent seulement 4 points d'eau
sur les 27 de la capitale on a
immédiatement arrêté localisation de
kato surtout me faire q pas seulement
sur les quatre coins lecture l'ensemble
des pierreries et nous n'utilisons plus
depuis hier que le circuit d'eau potable
y compris pour pour la question du
nettoyage de paris alors je vous dis est
ce que vous êtes inquiet ou pas moi
personnellement moi je vous dis moi je
suis inquiet déjà pour les personnes qui
travaillent avec cette eau là je vous le
dis et puis généralement quand ils nous
disent vous inquiétez pas ça risque rien
normalement tu sais que dans deux trois
semaines
tu vas voir tu sais pas pourquoi il ya
un cannois
un canon camions poubelles qui va pas
démarrer à bah ouais mais c'est parce
que c'est lola du corps on a des ruches
technique tu as un prix qui va se passer
c'est sûr et certain je la sens pas
cette affaire valérie non une chose est
sûre c'est que effectivement la mairie
de paris moi je la crois quand elle dit
qu'il n'y a pas de possibilité que
l'autre potable aille avec l'eau non
potable etc
mais peu importe de s'axer sur sa nature
est simple mais ceux-ci ceci étant posé
moi j'ai entendu hier j'imagine que vous
aussi vous avez regardé la conférence de
presse olivier ferrand et du premier
ministre il y avait une infection qui
était invité et qui expliquait ce qu'on
savait du virus est ce qu'on ne savait
pas et moi ce que j'ai remarqué c'est
qu'on ne savait pas beaucoup de choses
de ce virus il a mais on ne sait pas si
on peut être à nouveau une fois qu'on a
eu la maladie atteindre à nouveau
affectée on ne sait pas yahia lens el
flaco si on ne sait pas si cette flotte
elle peut éclaboussé la condamine et
enfin voilà quoi
et ben ali mais c'est pas là elle fait
pas l'aude aquaboulevard non plus
éclaboussé s'ils vont pas des cadeaux et
non pas de piscine à vagues avec l'eau
du corps aux navires lieutenant michael
dit tu crois pas qu'il y aura des gars
c'est pas pris part comme comme les
municipaux par exemple l'état ivoirien
n'est pas mais je pense à moi oui moi je
mens sur toile gilles verdez après le
personnel effectivement je suis
entièrement d'accord et nous le
personnel mois cyril par exemple je vais
vous dire franchement moi je suis à
paris je bois de l'eau du robinet eh ben
je vous assure que à partir d'un mot
j'ai entendu ça j'ai flippé
parce que bien sûr disais ouais y'a rien
après on nous dit bon alors l'eau non
potable
le pauvre personnel déployant et puis
très vite la mairie à régime et moi
quand on réagit très vite pour toujours
ça suspect quelle analyse ils ont sp
dans quelques semaines comme nous le
suggérions va pas nous dire bah
finalement l'eau potable aussi pour moi
ça manque de transparence et je vous le
dis sincèrement depuis cette annonce la
jeune fille vraiment avec l'eau
légèrement c'est chez moi tous ceux qui
nettoient et qui eux risquent d'être
contaminées vraiment quoi ça sert et moi
je veux bien
je mènerai croire c'est vrai qu'il
existe deux réseaux différents comme tu
l'as dit l'eau non potable qui est pris
à paris et l'eau potable des parisiens
qui arrive en amont du sud de paris par
le baron haussmann à café les travaux
c'est un jeu c'est de l'eau est à sens
et haussmann est belle grande qu'on fait
ça à l'époque en 1850 passé 10 mois et
stéphane bern ou c'est raymond la non
ils ont fait des travaux n'est pas de la
seine et marne
donc pourquoi loca rives de seine et
marne et serait pas terminée on arrivera
à paris et pourquoi la seule serait
contaminée moi c'est ça leur explique
qu'on m'explique que la seine et marne
elle va bien et là ça ne va pas bien
c'est bizarre quand même
je sais que tu rieuse méthode weight en
attendant cabinet in-stat peut-être une
explication mais juste avant je voudrais
rené ouais on est non mais moi je ce qui
me chagrine mais je dis que c'est que
même comique hong kong chine et je sais
qu'à on sait pertinemment qui en a qui
sortent il va se prendre le bec
nous ici on a vu bien la kfa louis le b
alors là quand tu prends le big calm and
d'alto garde le mal des risques assez le
tournage de plus belle la vie
bien sûr et c'est plus belle la vie ça
c'est parce que je reviens pas de voir
des gars n'est pas perdu et non mais
t'as du gat a dû voir des gars saint
tropez qui tournait sous le soleil
t'emmerde pas qu'ils aient bien rené
revol est là mais je sais sophie ça
plusieurs semaines je sais pas si vous
avez vu ça qu'on nous dit en fait que
l'eau potable est de plus en plus
chlorée elle n'arrive pas nous donner
une explication alors alors actuelle
inquiète je vais vous j'ai vu que tu es
un article sur le sujet et je vais vous
donner à dominer de sophie je vais vous
donner juste déjà depuis quelques jours
vous avez remarqué que certains ont
remarqué que leur peau et est plus sèche
que d'habitude
après la douche entre les démangeaisons
et le goût de l'eau du robinet qui
change tout ça se réduit à la
concentration de chlore qui aurait été
augmenté ces derniers temps regarder
pourquoi regarder ce sujet de ces voix
là depuis un peu plus d'une quinzaine de
jours certains des habitants de la ville
de saint cloud ont constaté une
différence lors de leur toilette
quotidienne
j'ai la peau
un peu plus sèche quand je sors de la
douche alors que j'ai pas changé b de
produits et des enfants qui se plaignent
de se gratter de démangeaisons et qui se
grattent matin et soir ils prennent des
douches deux fois par jour et ça la
démange
quand il sort de la douche rien de
surprenant les dosages en chlore ont été
augmentés dans l'eau courante de
plusieurs villes de l'ouest de la région
parisienne camions poubelles et les
parcs et jardins
voilà alors aux îles valérie blais
vouliez des voulu ajouter des choses je
voulais dire en revanche je revenais sur
ce que disait gilles régis voit des
complots partout et d'un manque de
transparence
mais bon il ya beaucoup de transparence
et pour nous dit tout et que des
caméléons dit merci on a perdu benhaim
elle est en train de dire que des capés
de travers en holliger boisset aux
matelots syrie voire virus se dire
attends tu prends quelques couloirs
cabanon ça c'est que pour les camions
poubelles et les parcs et jardins est ce
assez pour notre table emballant neuvy
russie va pas sur l'eau potable
il va te sur lesquelles on pouvait les
jardins tu crois bien vivre aussi bien
au stadium siné dont l'eau non potable
il est dans l'eau potable donc j'ai
l'avenir sous raymond il croit que le
virus soit que c'est un mec normal il
est comme un très bon jeu faire de l'eau
potable mais pas tout de suite je suis
pas encore prêt tu vois là tout de suite
je suis pas dans l'autre tu as peut-être
dans deux ou trois mois mais là non
voilà non visage et voilà ça fait mais
j'ai rejoint des infos je retrouve
d'abord valérie telles qu'elles étaient
c'est à dire aussi intelligente que
naïve
valérie vous le disais vous même on ne
sait pas on ne sait pas on ne sait pas
donc quand on ne sait pas on ne se
précipite pas pour réagir franchement
effectivement comme disait raymond moi
je connais très bien le confluent de la
seine et de la marne
donc ça veut dire qu il y aurait eu en
fait les attendant tu connais tu connais
tu pas le comtois tout court non mais la
raison ce qui va dire écoutez ce qu'il
va dire et alors vas-y confluent de la
scène et âme à ces alfortville maisons
alfort vous avez les deux qui se
rejoignent là à ce moment là à ce moment
là ça veut dire que les puits d'eau
potable alors certes ces filtres et les
puits d'eau potable aurait dérivation
pour arriver jusqu'à 12 ans et les plus
de virus here est ailleurs et très
franchement il ya une inquiétude mais
non mais n'essayez pas d'en fumer l'opow
valérie benaïm vous êtes alors s'il vous
plaît gilles verdez qui connaît beaucoup
de conflits ont un vous l'avez remarqué
quand on l'a on la coupe et on la coupe
évasée valérie non mais ce que je veux
dire à gilles c'est que moi je refuse
qu'on dise qu'il ya un manque de
transparence
bien au contraire je trouve qu'à chaque
fois qu'il se passe quelque chose y
compris des choses on arrive a expliqué
on nous
et on vous dit quoi pour la première
fois j'ai entendu et un président et un
minime et et dessiner mais l'armée laval
et valérie zepa valérie que là on fera
un pas de ça on parle de l'amérique
paribas nourricier soyez mon parc de la
mairie de paris la mairie de paris on
les avait pas entendu je suis désolé
l'amérique pendant les élections
la mairie de paris c'est encore en train
de construire et noir de russie les tsr
tu crois qu anne hidalgo l'acsa foot
vallée encore dans des travaux là je
t'explique lan hidalgo elle avec une
pioche un marteau elle en train de
casser des trucs là tu crois quoi elle
est en train de faire des couloirs de
bus et des noms mais je te le dis elle
en train de faire des pistes cyclables
donc arrêtez de nous prendre la tête